okay Donald Trump has been casting doubt
on Russian interference into the
election of course that goes counter to
the opinion of the FBI that goes counter
to the opinion of the CIA and all week
Trump has been teasing a briefing on the
issue of Russian hacking which was
supposedly set to happen earlier this
week and now Donald Trump has taken to
his official means of communication de
facto which is Twitter and said that the
hearing was delayed and that it was
moved to friday and Trump use this
alleged rescheduling as evidence that
there's something really weird going on
here he actually tweeted this uh over
the last 24 hours 48 hours rather quote
the intelligence briefing on so-called
quote Russian hacking was delayed until
Friday perhaps more time needed to build
a case very strange and of course Trump
using scare quotes around both
intelligence and Russian hacking there
now immediately when Trump said oh I was
going to be briefed on this day and now
not being briefed till Friday it's
really really weird senior US
intelligence officials immediately said
actually that's not true the meeting was
always scheduled for Friday this was a
briefing with the NSA and the CIA and
the director of national intelligence
and the FBI they said no Trump is just
lying we haven't rescheduled it the
entire narrative is absolutely false
Trump doubled down on his apparent
doubts about Russia's involvement uh
yesterday morning citing the interview
that WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
did with sean hannity which we talked
about earlier in the show what what the
hell is going on around here Pat I just
think that Donald Trump doesn't need an
intelligence community he seems to know
everything about cyber security yeah he
said that it's nearly impossible to
catch someone unless you catch them in
the act in like a smart person as he
said once sure yet and during uh the
debate when there was a accusation
against Russia packing the DNC that he
said well you don't know if it's Russia
you don't know if it's China it could be
a 400-pound man on a bed somewhere yeah
and he also talked about how his 10 year
old son it's amazing what he can do with
computers that was apparently
part of the context I guess of trumps
understanding of the cyber intelligence
world so the president-elect cites a Fox
News interview with the WikiLeaks
founder who just months ago was the
enemy of the American right in terms of
supporting what he believes while he
doesn't trust our own intelligence
agencies which he will be overseeing as
president and presumably depending on
these are some strange times that we are
living in and if you want to be
skeptical because the legitimacy of your
election win is on the line I get that
right Trump if he concedes or admits
that hey you know what a foreign actor
did influence the election in a way that
helped me win that significantly damages
the legitimacy and mandate of your
presidency both of which are
significantly lacking for
president-elect Donald Trump but say you
know I'll review the evidence when it's
presented and go from there to go
national and just say I don't believe
all of our intelligence agencies instead
I take the word of a guy who money many
in my party wanted killed people in the
Republican Party and some of the
Democratic Party alluding to the idea of
the death penalty for Julian Assange
that is not the way that the
president-elect should be behaving he is
in a sticky situation though but from
everything we've seen from it's not
surprising that he would take his own
ego in the short term yeah then these
intelligence officials that he's going
to be overseeing in the near future yeah
WikiLeaks and Julian Assange support the
pre-existing beliefs and desires of
Donald Trump's ego the national
intelligence agencies have put out
information that doesn't so Trump
ignores those instead quotes Assange on
Fox News talking to Sean Hannity send me
your thoughts about this i'm on twitter
at d pakman the show is on twitter at
david packard show today's program is
brought to you in part by blue apron i
received this week's blue apron delivery
a couple of days ago and I've sort of
become a big advocate of blue apron and
the big thing for me is whenever I want
to cook anything I end up with too many
ingredients and I'm not planning
correctly as to what I'm going to do
with the leftovers after I use
half of my bunch of celery for my soup
what do I do with the other half
sometimes I figure out what to do with
it sometimes it goes bad blue apron
ships to you the exact amount of each
ingredient required for the recipes that
you select which drastically reduces
food waste it should reduce it to zero
and it also allows you by sending you
the pre-portioned and measured
ingredients as well as the recipe it
lets you and your family cook together
as we talked about recently when we
learn about the blue zones around the
world where we have the highest and
longest life expectancy one of the
common things in those cultures is that
people regularly cook together with
actual fresh ingredients now some of the
meals available in January spaghetti
squash and marinara with mushrooms and
garlic knots that would be vegan
producer Pat approved you also have the
spicy shrimp and Korean rice cakes with
cabbage I actually made this last night
uh those Korean rice cakes I've never
seen anything like them before very
tasty very very good you can check out
this week's menu and get your first 3
meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue apron dot-com / Pakman
that is blue apron dot-com / PA ke ma n
blue apron a better way to cook